all right we're just gonna start off
with with a bang here 20 years from now
Bitcoin where are we and not answers a
price but can we get to a global reserve
currency can we get to it being used
kind of coexistence with with the US
dollar what do you think is possible
here sure so I think that right now
bitcoin is a global settlement layer
we're seeing that Bitcoin settles you
know right now between one and two
billion dollars a day right notional
which is in US dollars which is
substantial amount of money I think that
over the next 20 years that number is
only going to continue to go up I think
over the next 20 years we will have
figured out you know ways to make
Bitcoin viable for small-scale payments
as well which won't be which I don't
believe are going to be on chain I think
in terms of its existence in the global
financial system I see over the next 20
years I think it's entirely possible
that you know central banks will hold
Bitcoin reserves I don't know that it
can achieve any sort of reserve status
currency over the next 20 years even in
our wildest dreams but I think it's
entirely possible that it plays a
significant role especially as smaller
developing currencies start to collapse
I think what people often forget is that
the median lifespan of most nations
state-issued currencies isn't that long
right and sort of even you know the we
look at the US dollar as you know having
longevity and the US government being
the sort of lender of last resort but
you know and the US government in the
grand scheme of things has existed and
dollars have been in circulation for a
substantial amount of time but I think
that especially with much smaller
currencies we're seeing what happens
with poor monetary policy we're seeing
it in you know Iran and Venezuela and
you know Turkey now and you know I saw
that I think you put out the tweet
earlier this week that Roger versatile
but they were seeing we're seeing the
collapse of currencies all over the
world I think that there's a further
conversation to be had about you know
whether Bitcoin does become a global
reserve asset itself where and in this
process is what a lot of the Bitcoin
maximalist of a group where I would
consider myself firmly in consider a
sort of hyper Bitcoin ization right so
post type of equation Bitcoin is stable
enough to be a viable means of exchange
and unit of account all over the world
but I think you know well before that
there could exist you know sort of in
free banking type model nation state
issued currencies that are just pegged
to Bitcoin
you know similar to how we you we had
the gold standard and and before that in
in the late 19th century early 20th
century we had all sorts of you know
bimetallic pegs all of which collapsed
for really no for a host of reasons but
I think that the the first step in that
process will be actually returning to a
Bitcoin reserve and and this is
something that siphoning has covered in
detail in the Bitcoin standard and I
think sort of before that we'll see
we'll start to see a substantial growth
even from the volumes it's doing today
in bitcoins utility as a global
settlement layer you know where it's
already settling numbers that annually
are comparable to gold markets
absolutely ensue as this global
settlement layer becomes more prevalent
do you think that these smaller
currencies at smaller markets actually
gravitate towards it in the short term
or do you think it's something where
they'll continue to kind of flounder and
really suffer until you know some other
event makes this overly attractive to
them later if you look at like you know
Turkey for example right now there's
some flight to Bitcoin but it's not you
know kind of half the economy right and
so how do you think about that yeah I
think that there's there's two ways of
thinking about it one is over a very
very long term view and the reality is
that in that very long term view so long
as it survives another day
you know bitcoins almost like a black
hole
it's a black hole sucking in all assets
that are you know weaker forms of money
I think that over a very very long time
horizon it's entirely possible that this
could include the US dollar on shorter
timeframes I think it's it's most
relevant to even see what's happening in
Venezuela for example where citizens are
swapping bolivars for you know primarily
dollars but also Bitcoin because even
dollars you know despite the fact that
there's substantial number of dollars
that are printed every year are still
significantly harder form of money than
bolivars and I think that what will
happen over time is you know that people
will always have the the sort of
inclination to you know use their their
weak forms of money and and to acquire
and hoard stronger forms of money
especially if they don't have whites for
an access to it like they do Bitcoin and
so yeah in the short term I think that
we'll start to see you know the shift in
economies where they absolutely have to
or they have no other choice
so in Venezuela even if you had bought
Bitcoin at the highest possible local
rate at the peak of the market in
December your purchasing power in you
know relative to bolivars would still be
twice you know what it would be if you
would have bolivars despite the fact
that Bitcoin has dropped by a factor of
three and and so I think that in the
short term will start to see shifts
where people have no other choice
especially in countries that have
significant capital controls where
they're still able to bring in Bitcoin
and and in the long term we'll see what
we'll have to I think that it's
inevitable that we'll see it we'll see a
convergence effect there